Moscow has reported two drone strikes on
all the refineries in southern Russia
they happen in the krasnodar region
State media say one of the strikes
caused a fire at the facility it's since
been extinguished Russia says there was
no damage from a drone crash yet the
Husky Refinery Moscow has blamed kiev
for an increasing number of attacks on
its territory
for more let's speak with Julia in
Moscow you know first up what's the
kremlin's reaction to this
well actually we hadn't heard any
reaction from the Kremlin on that
particular case what we know so far on
Wednesday morning yet another drone
attacks were reported and now the afib
scale oil refinery in the krasnada
region was targeted and various telegram
channels uh here wrote it was a
Ukrainian drone but officially that
hasn't been confirmed the attack took
place around 4 30 a.m and right after
that a major fire started at the site
one of the oil units caught fire but
according to reports it was a rather
quickly extinguished and no one was
injured and basically it's not the the
fast attempts to attack various Refinery
facilities in the krasnada region but
they all have been beaten off by
refineries Personnel so far how does
this drone strike fit into previous
attacks
well interesting we can say that almost
every day is something extraordinary
takes place here in Russia and you
probably remember a drone strike on the
Kremlin Palace earlier on May the 3rd
arrayed by the so-called Liberty of
Russia Legion in the Belgard region an
attack on a Black Sea Fleet ship
Tuesday's massive drone attacks here in
Moscow and in the Moscow region so there
is an opinion that all of them are
allegedly part of a series of operations
before the so-called Ukrainian
counter-offensive and all those
incidents were serving to draw the
Russian attention away and weaken its
forces probably and sadly there are
expectations here that all the
extraordinary things will continue here
as long as the conflict between Russia
and Ukraine rages on
Julia thanks for that update to Julia
thank you